barre symbolique des dix mille morts
dépasse et en espagne 9 150 nouveaux
décès en 24 heures les malades prise en
charge par les services médicaux se
retrouvent parfois isolées jusqu'à leur
mort difficile pour eux et pour leurs
proches est privé du dernier au revoir
quant à mme auclair et grégoire douce et
deuxième foyer européen de la pandémie
due qu'aux vide 19
l'espagne voit sa situation se
détériorait jour après jour si l'armée
est déployée dans les rues pour faire
respecter les mesures en vigueur
elle ne peut rien faire face à la
solitude des personnes infectées
dès qu'un malade monte dans une
ambulance
il lui est désormais interdit d'avoir
tout contact avec ses proches
c'est vraiment très difficile en ce
moment je n'ai pas vu ma vie depuis
quatre ans et voilà qu'on doit lui dire
adieu
ils achèteraient être malade et isolés
dans les derniers moments de sa vie
c'est une triste réalité qui plane
actuellement sur l'espagne pour la
famille et les proches
impossible de dire au revoir impossible
également d'organiser des funérailles
publiques seulement trois personnes
peuvent être présentes à l'enterrement
et ce quelle que soit la cause du décès
ils ont tout fait pour nous toute leur
vie ma grand-mère a consacré quatre à
six ans à sa famille à ses petits gens
et maintenant des gens meurent
seelandaise adieu sans que cette idée
m'attriste de nombreux lieux sont quant
à eux deux transformé en morgue
temporaire pour entreposer les corps des
défunts dans la tente de la crémation ou
de l'enterrement
comme ici à la patinoire de madrid
devoir affronter un deuil seule une
véritable épreuve à surmonter
le plus difficile a dit qu'on ne peut
pas partager la douleur éprouvée face à
la perte d'un proche campagne là où nous
sommes désolés nous ne pouvons pas aller
à l'hôpital pour être avec nous à leur
chat nous sommes obligés de 10
une perte de manière inhabituelle et est
à la solitude face à la saturation des
hôpitaux le personnel médical tente de
s'adapter pour faire face à l'afflux
toujours aussi important de patients de
nombreux patients qui il y à quelques
temps avant le virus aurait été admis
dans une unité de soins intensifs ne
peuvent plus être soignées dans ces
unités et sont laissés progrès net ou
plutôt ne peuvent pas s'en sortir
et puis nous essayons d'autres solutions
moins conformistes comme l'adaptation de
masques de plongée sur les appareils
respiratoires
mais cela nécessite néanmoins un
dispositif ventilation dont nous n'avons
pas encore assez d'unités
le pic de l'épidémie n'est toujours pas
été atteints et l'espagne comptent déjà
des milliers de morts et plus de cent
mille cas répertoriés seule bonne
nouvelle
plus de 22 mille personnes sont
considérés comme guéris